[Music]
your wait is there a process or
something that you do to yourself so
raise your awareness to see new things
so that you can always kind of be on
track will be even ahead of where you
want to go for me it's developing a
self-awareness starts with figuring out
your one word we talked about this I
think before in other videos but I
believe everybody has one word that kind
of define to them and you need to
understand what that is so you're
constantly living your true value so for
me it's believed you know you got
inspire as you look at your work as you
look at your life it now becomes like if
that's who you truly are if you're
really about inspire and then you look
at your videos and you look at your
marriage you look at your kids and you
look at your house and you look at like
everything it applies it it's the most
important core value for you yeah it's
the lens which they lend like I believe
you're inspired like it's close but
we're not the same either right and
somebody else who picks inspire your
inspire be a little different than
theirs but at least you know and you're
always going to be unhappy in a
situation where there's no inspiration
if your marriage doesn't have any more
inspiration you're going to be upset
it's going to lead to unhappiness if
your work is boring you're going to feel
boxed in there's no inspiration you're
going to keep going to need you're going
to be upset you're going to have to find
a change right and so a lot of people
don't know what they're they just feel
the angst without having a solution so
understanding what your one word is is a
great start so that you can say okay you
know what I don't have enough inspire my
life I don't have enough believed in my
life I got to go find a way to inject
some of that I mean start to feel good
again through your business to your
career through your marriage all of that
stuff that's the starting point
I think then it's overcoming the fear to
go and do it I think building the
muscles that's important and I think the
best way to do it is through your
environment I think a lot of people
would be in a situation where they're
like okay it's great I'm about inspired
you know I have I have my own business
and I love it inspired great okay I'm
going to go off in today's a day now I'm
going to hear all the ten ways I can
inject some inspiring you around fire
like finally
yeah I got life into me like who is this
new person and then it all falls apart
like the next day you're up and what was
that I was smoking yesterday it's like
it's gone you're back to your crappy
life what happened because because your
life doesn't support it you have a big
goal and then your environment doesn't
match the goal and so you fall right
back down like if you want to learn
French the fastest way to go to France
like be immersed you're forced to learn
it if you just try to pick it up from an
audio book once a week like you're not
gonna not going to happen for you right
you got to live it you got and your
environment needs to scream it right so
whatever it means to you like what is
inspire who who's the most inspiring
person to you if it's Albert Einstein if
it's Quentin Tarantino if it's like
whoever I'm not judging like you love
Che Guevara or whatever right like yeah
put the I mean we just went to the story
the picture of the girl the girl that I
couldn't catch you know on to my wall
help me I touched it is it okay the
picture on the wall help me make the
hard decision in my life where normally
I probably would have backed down but
because I saw that daily I didn't want
to live with regret again I reminded
myself of the pain of not asking that
girl to coffee and then that let me make
the most important decision in my life
and so you need to be surrounded by
inspire you need to have it it's your
physical environment right what's on the
wall what's on the floor like you need
to be in a you can't live in a box like
for someone who loves inspire you can't
live in a cookie cutter box it's not
inspiring right you need to do something
funky with your space right your space
has to reflect your inner self or vice
versa as you create with things in your
space that affect himself think about
the big goal you have when you have
those moments of boldness like the
ultimate rich or the ultimate Jane or
the ultimate you know Johnny what
environment is he or she in what is this
space scream and and and maybe the
ultimate vision is yes I'm in Maui and
I've got like a balcony look okay great
start with a picture of Maui on the wall
right like you know you Kate
ciseaux ciated with some of these things
you want to do so start start smaller
right like I want to be around Steve
Jobs and his big thinking okay it's not
possible he's dead I've never met him
and I never will but I could put his
picture in the wall that might cost me
you know 20 bucks or whatever it is and
that injects a little bit of Steve into
me every day when I go in physical space
is important from there you look at your
your habits your routines your the
content that you really like are you
what are you reading books that make you
inspired are you reading you know People
magazine or whatever right like not to
get down in People magazine but like
look at look at what content you're
consuming and does it help you become
that person now somebody who somebody
whose word might be security you know
maybe a box is perfect for them they
don't want the chaos of switching up
lightbulbs and like putting new carpets
in and new stuff on the wall like all
that uncertainty is not great for them
they couldn't live in that crazy
environment great go live in the box
it's perfect but then you need to have
other things around security that make
you feel like you're you're you're in
charge of what you're doing so we talk a
physical environment look at the people
in your life do the people and you're
really inspiring the people that you
talk to daily do they inspire you or do
they just like if you tell them this
crazy idea that you have they're like oh
yeah yeah okay good or even worse like
you can't do that like you go to you to
go to school to do that rich like what
do you not so if you kid
you not how are you going to be
photographer you to go to school for
that you know you don't family
connections there just was housing
photographers what makes you so special
right like there's a lot of people that
that's those are the people in their
life that's not that's not inspire right
and so the people in your life the books
you read the videos you watch and an
easy way to kind of figure that out is
think about we've all had moments like
you've had moments in your life where
you've been that best that you've had
moments you've been super inspired what
was happening there was it watching a
Tony Robbins video was it doing some
adventurous thing with your wife was it
you know reading
to your kids whatever it is write it
like not judging whatever it is that you
need to do now instead of having that
happen randomly at five o'clock on a
Monday afternoon because you happen to
turn on you know a YouTube channel build
it into your routine like yeah yeah with
purpose yeah start every day with this
stuff whatever it is right you're like
if you need to to wake up scratch your
back run in a circle for three minutes
I don't care like if that's what gets
you to be that because I mean I we set
every day I well I feel great now like
you got me pumped up right it we're
spreading some love rays is amazing
right I'm going into some other
interviews and stuff after today and
tomorrow morn I'm going to wake up and I
got to start over
it started square one every day right
and so I need to I inject believed into
my life daily you need to I know I think
this is where a lot of people fall down
because they think because I'm inspired
now that's it's my new way of being and
when they wake up the next morning or
next day or next week and it's not
they're like ah that didn't work that
stuff it's gone yeah this is good this
is likely going to be my advice it's the
next book money it's give me the next
book the first book is on finding your
one word the self-awareness and then the
next one is probably going to be on
designing that environment because
because that's what holds people back
the environment your environment sucks
yeah maybe I'll call that that's the
name of the book your environment sucks
yeah and I think also people's
expectations English it's done in space
and then when it's not they don't have
that persistence I can have been
entrepreneurs then you really have to
persist yeah you're going to fail now
you're going to fail again and again you
got to keep persisting a lot of people
think I tried once maybe I'll try twice
we didn't work out that's it I'm done
I'm going back to my old way I'm really
to ask them be present it's an everyday
moment-to-moment thing yeah I mean I
think I think the only way that that
works is if you enjoy the work if we're
talking about entrepreneurship now like
most entrepreneurs fail I think a big
reason is people look up they pull out a
magazine of the top hundred businesses
start in 2017 like notes of number one
photography great I'm going to be on I'm
going to be a photographer in 20
17 right and then they're going to go up
against people like you who have a
passion for what you're doing and it's
an art form and you've injected your
personality and creativity and you're
going to crush them and they're going to
try and it's going to be hard and
they're going to quit like if you're
only chasing the end goal you're never
going to get there you gotta check with
yourself really please I know we've
spoken on before it's really you know
you don't talk about it that much really
feeling kind of thing seems like if you
feel good about it if you love it if you
enjoy be doing as soon as you don't want
to do it you won't force yourself which
is counterintuitive we're not
counterintuitive but it's counter to the
way everything's running Society you
have to go to work at 8:00 or 9:00 and
you just have to go to school and just
have to do basically that you do it
whether you like it or not so if you see
this backwards isn't it you only do it
if you really want to do it it's not
about that yeah like the more the more
you know everybody has bad days and it's
not all gravy and amazing and like in my
life - I have bad days but if I find
myself doing the same thing repeatedly
and I and I like it
less and less and less and less and less
so like okay I got it like this has to
be cut somehow like if it's important to
the business then then I'm going to hire
someone to do it it was not important to
the business and it's it's out I'm going
to do something else we did a top ten on
Jerry Seinfeld recently and one of the
things he was talking about was doing
doing the work that other people find
torture the torture that you enjoy so
people look at my schedule and within a
YouTube context you know I'm filming we
feel at least three videos a day go up
on the YouTube channel where a lot of
people have a hard time making a video a
week we're doing three a day people
would look at my schedule and say that's
insane
it's torture who would want to do that
right and I would look at yours and say
rich you're nuts right I don't want to I
don't want to sit there and edit video
when like that's torture man like you
put me in your job I would be I would I
would probably pick up a smoking habit
or something do it like I'd be obvious
like you know because it's torture I
would hate it right but for you it's
love for me I love doing it like this
does not work for me for a lot of people
like ah got to do another stupid
interview you know whatever you're like
and they hate it right it won't be a
Brady of you I love this I get jazzed up
this right I'm leaving this on a high
right I love it and so too many people
are just addicted to the outcome where
you have to enjoy the process you got to
enjoy the work so if he's I get what I
do and it doesn't work and I do and it
doesn't work okay we keep doing it you
do it to do it you do it because you
love doing it and you'll figure out a
way to make it work not just chasing the
work and then whatever I have to do to
to make it work right you'll never get
there the people who have had success in
any field entrepreneurship or career or
anything
they love the business they love getting
up and doing the work they may not love
every day or every part of it it's not
all roses but they like the work and
when other people look at your schedule
it looks like torture
you
[Music]
you